all right 6 26 on your friday morning
something that may drive you crazy
anybody driving on the 95 515 on the
east side of town this weekend down to
one
lane in each direction between boulder
highway and flamingo and dot's putting
the finishing touches on the work that's
been going on there for the past year or
so you can see the cones ready to go
into action now because of heat during
the day most of the work is going to be
during the overnight hours and that's
justin hopkins telling us that hey if it
looks like there's nothing going on
there during the day
don't freak out it's because the overlay
that they're putting down here it's been
added to the roadway has to cure during
the day so justin suggests giving
yourself plenty of time to get through
the area or better yet skip the freeway
use surface streets the work again
starting at nine tonight running until
five monday morning buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
something's driving you crazy email me
traffic eight at eight news now dot com